eldon ring has 10 starting classes to
choose from all of which offer their own
unique pros and cons so let's take a
look at each one to help you figure out
which is best for you
the hero is a straightforward melee
focused class that begins the game with
high strength endurance and vigor stats
alongside a one-handed axe and a
medium-sized shield for some extra
protection in a pinch this no-frills
class should make dark souls melee fans
feel right at home as a hero your
primary stats will likely continue to be
strength and vigor strength will ensure
that you can wield large weapons that
scale specifically with that stat while
having a high health pool with your
increased vigor stat will assist you
with the fact that you'll spend most of
your time in close quarters and counters
the bandit doesn't bring much to the
table for the more commonly desired
traits instead offering a lot of points
in arcane some high dexterity is helpful
too though all of the other stats begin
at fairly low levels that being said the
bandit begins the game with the dagger
and bow and arrows making it the perfect
stealth based starting class if that's
your thing the arcane stat helps you
find more items on defeated foes and has
some use in certain sorceries and
incantations but it's best suited for
niche builds and won't be optimal for
more typical play styles as such the
bandit isn't one of the better starting
classes for most players who want to min
max their stats at the end of the game
the vagabond is a tried and true knight
coming equipped with heavy armor a
straight sword and a solid shield in
preparation for close quarters showdowns
its high starting vigor makes it the
tankiest of the starting classes while
the nearly even split between strength
and dexterity makes it perfect for
quality builds which bring both stats to
at least 40 to specialize equally in all
melee weapon types the vagabond's low
intelligence faith and mind stats don't
do much to set it on a path for using
sorcery or incantations but they're not
so low that you couldn't pump a few
points in them to make use of spells as
a backup option but if magic is
something you're wanting to use more
frequently you're much better off with
the class that specializes in it
the astrologer is a class that is really
well suited to newcomers who want to
have both melee and sorcery options in
battle this magic based class comes
equipped with a staff for casting
sorceries and a short sword for some
light melee it boasts large bonuses to
intelligence and mind that ensure that
you'll hit hard and have plenty of casts
at your disposal for ranged combat
making the most of the astrologer will
mean spending the majority of your
points in intelligence to keep your
magic damage high unless you want to
rely heavily on a melee weapon as a
backup option you'll want to pump up
your mind stat too so you can increase
the number of times you can cast spells
as long as you can keep a little
distance between yourself and your
enemies you'll find a lot to love here
the warrior is a dual-wielding
powerhouse for fans of fast-paced melee
combat it starts off with a high
dexterity stat and two simmeters so you
can dish out some hefty damage at the
expense of limited defensive options
this class is wonderful if you're open
to benefiting most from smaller weapons
and getting good use out of a bow
however bear in mind that your vigor
starts pretty low and you'll need to
dump a significant amount of runes into
your strength stat if you plan to wear
heavier armor in other words be sure
you're comfortable with keeping things
light and mobile if you're signing up
for this quick hitting lower defense
option
the first thing you're likely to notice
about the prisoner class is its unusual
iron mask strange in appearance as it
may be the prisoner is a solid pick if
you're wanting to make an agile melee
slash casting hybrid character it starts
with high dexterity and intelligence
stats and its starting gear is an stock
and a staff for casting sorceries you'll
need to either be adept at rolling or
make up a lot of ground in vigor and
endurance to make this class a little
more feasible for long-term melee
engagements as it starts with low hp and
stamina nevertheless this remains one of
the best starting classes if you'd like
to focus pretty equally on magic and
swordplay
the confessor is a hybrid class that
comes with plenty of points in faith
while also having solid strength and
dexterity stats which makes it a good
choice if you're looking to use spells
while also having some freedom in weapon
choices it comes equipped with a
broadsword and a finger seal for casting
incantations if you're hoping to start
off your experience with a character
that can cast incantations without
sacrificing melee capabilities you may
enjoy the confessor your low starting
vigor however means that you won't be
able to take as many hits in the
beginning but you can raise that stat
for some extra protection if you're
hoping to stay in close quarters often
the profit is a faith build starting
class with a focus on using incantations
to deal damage and heal themselves and
their allies they begin with low vigor
but decent strength and they wield a
spear and a finger seal for casting
incantations this makes them a hybrid
class that should benefit you if you're
hoping to have melee options to
complement your healing and damage
spells the profit can be immensely
powerful when played to its strengths
and the ability to obtain and use those
healing spells can be invaluable if
you're comfortable being a glass cannon
that favors high mind and faith stats
over more health this class is a
fantastic choice just be sure you're
prepared to take time to prepare for
fights and stay mobile during them
the samurai comes equipped with a
powerful katana and a longbow as well as
visually impressive armor that fits its
namesake it's a class focused heavily on
dexterity though its decent spread in
both vigour and endurance ensures that
you're starting out with a little bit of
survivability too
you won't have much in the way of magic
due to low intelligence and faith but
that doesn't mean you can't invest in
those stats ultimately the samurai is no
doubt one of the more versatile starting
options but unless the aesthetic of the
class is important to you you'll likely
find that the vagabond is a better
option for hybrid builds
the wretch is a blank slate character
that starts with all stats set to level
10 and wields only a club for boinking
baddies this is a worthwhile option if
you merely enjoy the concept of starting
from nothing and having to scrounge for
loot and having even stats across the
board means you have a lot of freedom to
build your character however you'd like
the downside of the wretch is that
because every stat begins at 10 you
can't min max for optimized builds at
the pvp level cap no matter what build
you hope to achieve you'll always have a
few extra points in useless stats that
would have been lower on a specialized
starting class those few points won't
always make or break your build entirely
but pvp can be brutal so you should be
aiming to maximize your potential and
that'll never be possible here
the good news for anyone looking to dive
into elden ring is that the game's
starting classes don't force you to fit
any particular mould you're still free
to build your character any number of
ways by distributing points into
whatever stats you see fit a starting
class will simply provide you with some
gear and stat boosts that may benefit
you if you're looking to focus on a
specific play style but if you're the
type who wants to min max your stats for
an optimal pvp build it's definitely
worth picking a class that will most
suit whatever you're hoping to
accomplish going with a melee focused
starting class for instance may leave a
full-blown magic build with a few
displaced points by the time you reach
your self-imposed level cap those few
points may not make a significant
difference in terms of viability but in
a game where showdowns can come down to
the wire
every point in your favor is worth the
investment
for more elden ring guides as well as
our review make sure you subscribe to
gamespot and we'll see you next time
you